if you're playing the titanfall to
pre-alpha you may have noticed some new
green batteries littered around the
field
these batteries play into titanfall 2's
new rodeo system which I will explain
directly dooming it tighten through
rodeo is now a three step process first
up you need to get on top of one you can
do this through good old-fashioned
parkour or by using the new grapple line
when you make it on top for the first
time if your pilot will proceed to pull
out the battery exposing a hole through
the Titans armor your pilot will then
forcibly exit the Titan from the Titans
perspective there will be a warning that
they've been grappled and/or rodeo if
you have electric smoke immediately take
a knee and cook that pilot off your
whole like sizzling bacon warning
hostile pilot attached to halt any pilot
eliminated if not and the pilot gets
away with your first battery there will
be a very obvious orange indicator over
the enemy pilots head go stop them out
of existence and get your battery back
because it's yours
as a pilot who has the battery and is
now safely on the ground you can do one
of two things go find a friendly Titan
and insert the battery into their
cranium to give them a house shield
boost or continue to fight if you choose
to fight and the Titan is currently
staring in your direction get away and
wait for the indicator obviously
pointing out your location to cool down
then come back and get a ticket for the
second rodeo on the second round of
rodeo your pilot will go through an
animation of sinking a grenade into the
Titans new head hole if successful this
will put the Titan into a doom state
however unlike the previous game the
Titans health will not auto deplete and
they can still fight indefinitely phase
3 is for the pilot to hit the Titan with
Anne anti-titan weapon or get back on a
third time we recommend the weapon and
that's how it's done just remember as a
Titan you will have a grapple warning a
rodeo warning a big glaring orange
indicator of where the pilot went who
stole your battery and three separate
chances to punch Electric smoke flame
shield stop or shoot the pilot so don't
waste your chances finally as a pilot
always pick up stray batteries on the
field which appear on your mini-map and
put them into your own or any friendly
type do this often and at the end of
every Titan battle to keep your Titan in
full health and that's how you win good
hunting pilots
pilot control online thermal systems
functional hostile pilot contained and
destroyed